على قيد الحياه كلمه يتجدد معها الامل من
تحت الركام
151 ساعه تحت الانقاض قضاها الشاب عبد
الله تحت ركام منزله المدمر في هاتاي
التركيه متمسكا بالحياه
خرج الى النور بعد سبعه ايام منظومه
الركام مانحا بارقه امل بدات بالتضاؤل مع
اقتراب مرور اسبوع على الكارثه
ومنها طاي الحزينه لم تتوقف قصص النجاه
والصمود
موزين السيده ذات الاربعه وستين عاما لم
يهزمها الزلزال وقوته خرجت من بين الركام
بعد 150 ساعه عثرت عليها فرق الانقاذ وتم
نقلها الى المستشفى وسط صدمه وفرحه
المنقذين امل ضئيل تجدد باحتماليه العثور
على المزيد من الناجين وبتجاهل سباق الزمن
جهود فرق الانقاذ المتواصله تمكنت من
انتشار شخص عمره 50 عاما بعد اسبوع من
بقائه تحت الركام في انطاكيا اما الرضيع
ذو الاشهر السبعه فيها الطاي فقضى 140
ساعه تحت الركام قبل ان تنجح فرق اطفاء
تركيه من انقاذه وبين عمليه انقاذ واخرى
يقف العشرات من الاهالي الناجين بملامح
تعكس الما كبيرا يتجمهرون حول فرق الانقاذ
متشبسين بمعجزه العثور على احياء ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
[تصفيق]